Hello Ladies and gents. This is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode,
God damn optimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
You posting a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue infoscope.
That's the usual intro music,
but I'd like you to hear a brand new
version reimagined by none other than
Justin Barreda of the glitch mob.
Whenever you find yourself
on the side of the majority,
it's time to pause and reflect.
This podcast is brought
to you by Mizzen and main.
Don't worry about the spelling.
All you need to know is this.
I have organized my entire life around
avoiding fancy shirts because you have to
iron them. You sweat through
them, they smell really easily.
They're a pain in the ass.
Mizzen and main has given me
the only shirt that I need.
And what I mean by that and Kelly
Starr at loves the shirts as well,
is that you can trick people.
They look really fancy so you can take
them out to nice dinners, whatever,
but they're made from athletics,
sweat wicking material.
So you can throw this thing into your
luggage in a heap or on your kitchen table
like I did recently, and then pull
it out, throw it on with no ironing,
no steaming, no nothing. Walk out,
and you could probably wear this thing
for a week straight or make it your only
dress shirt and take it on trips
for weeks at a time. Never wash it.
It will not smell.
You will not sweat through it.
You got to check these things out.
So go to a four hour work,
week.com all spelled out,
four hour work,
week.com forward slash shirts and if you
order one of their dress shirts in the
next week, you will get a Henley shirt
for free. That's worth about 60 bucks.
So put them both in the cart.
You use the code,
Tim t I m and you will get the
Henley shirt for free. Check it out,
four hour work week.com forward slash
shirts and you'll see some of my favorite
gear including the one shirt that
I've been traveling with, 99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for
all things graphic design related.
Go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim
to see the projects that I've put up,
including the mockups and drafts of
the book cover for the four hour body.
As always,
you can subscribe to this podcast on
iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well
as every other episode by going to four
hour workweek.com forward slash podcast
spell it all out or you can go to four
hour workweek.com and just click on
podcast feedback. If you have feedback,
I would love your thoughts, anything at
all who you'd like to see on this show,
ping me on Twitter as a t Ferris, that's
twitter.com forward slash t f e R R,
I s s or on facebook@facebook.com forward
slash at Tim Ferriss with two r's and
two s's.
This is Tim Ferriss.
And welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss Show where I deconstruct world
class performers to find the tools,
tricks, routines, habits that you can use.
And of course those experts range from
billionaire investors to chess prodigies
to Arnold Schwarzenegger, to everyone in
between. And you do find commonalities.
And in this particular episode we delve
into a world that I know very little
about and that is the world of music.
We have Justin Beretta who is a
founding member of the glitch mob.
And if you haven't heard that name
or you don't recognize that name,
you will definitely recognize some of
their music and it could range from their
trailers and where the trailers
in which their features.
So you could list sincerely to
edge of tomorrow, Captain America,
Spiderman to their commercial work.
So commercials for Fiat,
Audi and so on.
They also debuted their last album,
love, death and mortality incredibly
well on billboard number one,
electronic album, number
one, indie labels, number
four, overall digital albums.
And this is fascinating because
from an entrepreneurial standpoint,
not only are they indeed are
not associated with a big label,
they're artists owned and
we delve into all of this.
How did they go from unknown to
on top of the world plankton,
90,000 people in Quebec
with dead mass for instance.
We dig into the war stories, the
creative stories, the process,
how that has been refined over time and
you get to hear some never heard before,
early drafts of some of their biggest
hits and Justin walks through exactly how
those were refined over time to become
what millions of people now love and
listened to all the time. It's a
fascinating discussion with an artist.
Even if you feel like you have
no interest in music process,
you will find things ranging from his
schedule to his meditative practice that
you can use. It's a really fun interview.
I hope you enjoy it. Without further ado,
here is Justin Burrito.
Justin, welcome to the show. Hey,
how's it going Tim? It's going well.
I appreciate you making the time.
And as a long time fan,
I appreciate you making the
music first and foremost.
Oh yeah. It's my pleasure to be here.
I'm a, I'm a huge fan of, of all the,
the four hour empire as well. So it's,
it's an honor to, to get to talk to you.
And I know we, I guess initially connected
via Twitter. I think it was, is how we,
we came in contact. Is that how the the
pieces came together? Yeah, I think so.
I think you, you had posted
something on sound tracking,
which is a app that we both used and I
started following on there and then, yeah,
we just kind of just
started chatting from there.
That had to be a year or two
ago. Yeah, yeah, it probably was.
And then I've continued as a consumer of
music and now we finally have a chance
to dig into the music. So the first
question I really wanted to ask you,
uh,
is.